好 大家好 欢迎收看星期三的饭来一张口。
我是老范
我是雪梨
咱们上一期很欢乐。
聊了一个七个亿 是不是。
给咱们聊的基本上就没必要了。
又是买地 又是买个大院子。
所以这一期我们就回归到我们在日本的生活。
来跟大家聊一聊日本的物价。
就是回归到现实生活。
我们该醒一醒
对
今天聊的这个也没有什么特别数据型的东西。
就是我们在这门十来年。
然后真的就是从衣食 住行各个方面。
我们感受到的物价的一个变化。
那首先第一个离不开的肯定是汇率了。
因为我和雪梨我们刚来的时候。
那个时候是要留学嘛？
所以那这真的就是揣着人民币在日本生活。
那这的汇率大概是6.7 不到7吧？
我刚才说还没有那么高吧？
应该是6出头
但是随着这个留学的年数的增加。
这个汇率就一直在往上升。
对 但是那这呢？
不管买什么东西
脑子里都会把这个价格自动换成人民币。
那个时候会比较典型。
但是我发现这个习惯。
其实我是延续到现在一直都是这样的。
而且那个时候汇率最高到6.7的时候。
我会想说
如果这个汇率可以一直延续下去。
到我们变成社会人。
然后变成在工作的时候。
也是这个汇率的话。
其实心里面那时候还是挺高兴的。
因为如果按照一个社会人起心。
是大概20多万的一个标准来看的话。
6.7那肯定就是134了嘛？
对呀？
我想啊 有时候这个企业还挺爽的。
比我在留学的时候打空要爽多了。
对 但是在当时的话。
其实对于初到日本来的。
我还是构成了很大的冲击的。
你想那边借家的一碗牛肉饭的话。
大概也就是381元起嘛？
但是按照当时的这个汇率。
或者说人民币的话。
也得将近30块钱了。
跟北京借家差不多。
我在国内活了20多年。
我就没吃过32多元一碗的饭。
而且还是小碗的
如果是普通的或者大碗的。
就得400多
但是那只感觉打工赚得也挺多的。
是
对吧 一个月挣不到10万块钱。
对 像咱们的话
随便打一打就能到10万左右。
对对对
所以那个时候就像刚才你说的那个。
有一个叛头在
有一个叛头
对对对 我现在挣的少。
我以后就赚得多了。
我毕业了以后
哪个毕业生不得是20来万起步。
对不对
我刚毕业 我就1万多块钱了。
是 虽然我现在挣10万。
但我以后翻倍
对呀？
谁能想到
对 当时就想着
以后等真的工作了 挣了日元了。
就再也不用去算这个汇率了。
但是生活就是很磨换。
就是我们在这过了10年了。
32年合同 32年合习。
对
怎么说呢 某种程度上。
我们实现了当年的梦想。
就是我们开始赚日元了。
确实挣到了2、3、10万日元了。
一个月
但是吧 汇率变了。
咱也没想到
那边6点都减净
气的汇率现在已经变成4点几了。
就甚至有一度跌破4的这个趋势当时。
然后其实心里还是挺害怕 挺焦虑的。
而且之前还在那个网上看到帖子。
有人说
他来这边旅游的时候。
用的是那个珠宝的黑段的汇率。
所以他的汇率是3.9。
我就想说
那如果真的有一天。
这个汇率掉到3开头的话。
我们在日本生活的这些外国人的话。
这个生活应该怎么办呢？
虽然说我们在日本是正日元 花日元。
可能这个汇率的变化对于我们的绝对生活。
没有什么太大的影响。
但是这边好说不好听。
你当时按照6的汇率来说的话。
25万就是1万5千块钱。
你这跟家里说
一月挣1万5千块钱。
对不对
你现在4点几
就是我什么都没干。
我这个工资就自动变少了30%。
对吧？
你现在4点几的汇率。
它也就是1万出头了。
而且像咱们同龄人。
在国内的这些同学来讲的话。
他们工作这么多年。
他们的工资
有可能都要比咱们水平要高很多了。
肯定比咱高
咱们身边国内的朋友们。
没有比咱们工资低的。
混的好的
要么就是做生意的。
要么就是进了那些国企。
市业边的
对
除了在家躺平的以外。
但凡要是挣钱的都比咱挣得多。
但凡要挣钱都在1万1千。
但是我也算了
只要咱们的汇率回到了6。
咱就不是最低的了。
我觉得你就有点做梦了。
它能从6变到4
就不能从4变到6。
它可能
虽然我知道这是一个周期。
就是从4到6的过程。
应该是非常的漫长。
咱不知道什么时候才能看见。
我们有生之年能不能看见。
还不知道
至少比当时从6降到4要长得多。
对
那降的确实挺快的。
咱也不知道为什么？
就是夸夸的看汇率就还降。
就可能因为咱们来了。
但是这个汇率降来了以后。
我就发现国内的朋友。
开始找我买东西了。
他们拿汇率一算
省了30% 省了40%。
然后跟我说你看这个。
有的话赶紧给我买了。
然后我和雪梨接到这个委托。
我们俩就跑到银座。
我们发现是个设置品牌。
门口去拍全中国人。
全在买买买
但你说到这个
其实我跟你的这个体感是相反的。
我刚来的时候有很多的。
国内的经济朋友
托我去给他们去买东西。
因为当时可能是觉得。
我刚到日本
然后他们可能对这边的东西。
比较好奇比较新鲜。
然后所以会有很多人来找我买。
但是都买啥呢？
这是一些药妆 日用品 设置品都有。
方方绵面的都有
或者是一些户外的品牌。
什么羽毛球 乒乓球 啪就这种的。
但是尤其是过了疫情之后。
因为疫情当中是没有什么人。
过来找买东西的
因为那时候物流
可能也不太方便
再加上大家
可能也没有这么大的需求了。
不是 也不是没需求了。
主要就挣不着钱了。
需求还是有的
你只要有钱就需求。
就是没有日本这边的需求了。
就可能是能找的一些品贴之类的。
但是过了疫情之后。
发现就更没有人来找我买了。
现在买的都是那种。
说是品 就是那种高价值的东西。
因为这个忽略差可以省出来不少钱。
但是这几年
尤其是疫情以后
你没发现吧？
咱们的一个跨境电商。
还有一个国际物流发展的特别快。
淘宝都有199免油的服务了。
然后拼多多也在海外开了。
专门的TIM的APP。
而且还有一个
就是咱们不管是机运也好。
还是游记也好
那个费用一直在马上降。
我觉得你说的这个。
其实是其中一个原因。
还有一个我觉得是。
由于汇率的下降
日本这边好多
之前比国内或者说海外。
要便宜的一些商品。
它开始涨价了
这个东西就变成了。
全世界全球是统一的价格。
所以其实你到日本来买。
它也没有一个价格的优势在。
这个就是因为这两年。
日本这个通胀起来了。
所以可能涨价是普遍性。
而且还有一个
我是最近才注意到。
一个特别恶心的一个事。
就是在当年
这个无影良品也好。
还是说优衣裤也好。
他们卖东西
就是国内和日本的价格。
真的就是一刀切的那种。
假如一条牛仔裤
在日本卖3999的话。
那么在国内就直接卖3999。
然后咱们在策划这期节目的时候。
然后我去查了一下。
现在国内的这个
无影良品和优衣裤的价格。
我就发现
日本的是在涨价
但是国内的是在降价的。
也就是说他们的差距。
越来越小了
对 就是按照现在的汇率。
换算完了以后
其实怎么说
日本是便宜的
但是就发现便宜不到多少了。
就更加没有那个价格优势了。
对 就是可能国内。
这几年的经济不太好。
大家都在降价
然后日本这几年
就是莫名其妙的有通胀了。
然后所有通胀都在涨价。
然后一涨一跌
就把这个价差拉平了。
对 所以这也就是为什么？
就是我的体验
可能跟你来说就是相反的。
其实是差不多的
只是说
现在来日本买的
要不就是进口的东西。
要不就是那些高捨的东西。
在日本它不是原产过。
它也是进口的
但是这个时候
人家定价就是
怎么说呢？
地域差还是有的
所以减去汇率以后。
其实还是能赚不少。
但是真的
如果是落到比较评价的。
什么药装
或者说是一些化妆品。
或者说是一些日本产的东西。
你就发现了价差
就没有这么大了
而且很多牌子
咱们现在在国内都能买得到了。
对 而且还有一些评替出现。
不需要代购了已经。
评替就是又便宜又好用。
就感觉厂商
把这个代购的消购杜死了。
我们直接在国内开个店。
你们也不能代购了。
对
所以现在我们身边人。
做代购的越来越少了。
你包括我们现在回国也是。
经常就是空着
那么一两个箱子直接回去。
回来的时候慢慢当当。
进货来了
对
这个跟当年差别特别大。
当年回去的时候
是可以带好多东西回去的。
然后基本上这一趟。
可以把这个机票钱。
都赚出来有的
但是现在的话就是。
第一个抓得比较严了。
第二个不赚钱了
甚至说人都没有这需求了。
然后除了这个汇率以外。
其实还让我有一些难受的。
就是身份的这个问题。
就是咱们留学那会。
那不是留学生吗？
所以只要是日本政府一发钱。
肯定有咱们
对
因为当时就算打工的话。
一年他也挣不到
那个需要交税的程度。
对
你只要是低于他
103还是130万来着。
低于那个金额以下。
你就是非课税的身份。
那么非课税的身份。
你就可以领到
政府发的补贴
对
所以疫情的那一阵。
真的领了不少钱
主要是那个时候是。
政府和学校和文部省。
分别都发了很多的钱。
对
就是全国统一的那个我收到了。
然后学校的
我们是发了5万
全国统一向政府
和文部省的话
分别给10万
没有
文部省没给我们
文部省给了
文部省给了钱了
就是文部省
专门发给学生的一笔钱。
没收到
10万
政府发的每一个公民的钱。
对 那个我收到了。
然后我们学校给了5万。
学校那5万我也收到了。
然后就是每一个市医所。
或者是区政府
在后续几年
其实又给每一个人。
发了5到10万不等。
那个好像我学校那边。
那个能美市
就给了3万也是4万。
反正给的挺少的
差不多
然后到后期的时候。
这个疫情到第3年。
或者说已经快结束那一阵。
补贴就比较少了
大概就是3到5万之间。
对
然后我变成磕睡了。
你太惨了
然后我又变成磕睡了。
那就没了
但是最开始的时候。
占了的便宜
还有一个啥呢？
就是我打工那地
当时不是要求那个自素吗？
所以当时
这个勇望的商场
也关门了一些日子。
但是你店关门了
你里面的那些
比如说该整理的东西。
或者说说该打扫的东西。
你要继续弄的
你不能说一直在那空着。
能不能机会了
尤其是衣服也啥的。
而且他也有一些轮转的。
周期比如进货
出货啥的
所以即使那这说是不开门的。
我们也是需要安排人去店里面上班的。
既由不是处于这个迅销集团。
迅销集团旗下的所有的店铺。
说即使不营业
所有的员工都按照80%还是60%的新资来发放。
这个新资怎么来算呢？
比如说我不是打工吗？
那么我前两个月
如果每周都打工是。
28个小时打满的话。
那么即使不开门
那一周到两周
我也是可以拿到
28小时的60%或者80%。
这个是公司发的钱。
然后再加上在这个期间。
你是可以去上班的。
因为他有需求
那么这钱是另算的。
哦这是另算的
那只能说你们这个公司真的是。
非常替员工着想
对
所以那个时候我一月挣的钱。
要比我正常打工要多的。
因为当时是日本人都。
不太想去上这个班。
因为当时确实日本这个门。
闹得挺凶的
就是做严重的那种。
对
但是我无所谓
我有钱挣就行
所以我就把这个
当时的这个勤务都填满了。
因为学校也不用去了。
都自缩了
去什么学校对吧？
课也停了
学校也不用去了
研究室也不用去了。
所有东西都转成online的了。
一个礼拜就开那么个。
半个小时一个小时的会。
其他时间我就一直带他打工。
好了不好钱
对
你想我打工打28个小时。
然后他额外发我28%的60%。
85%忘记了
然后那个一个月
加上拉奇巴刀的补助吧？
得有个30万这个。
对得挣了32多万。
比现在还要多一些。
因为那件事
你不用扣什么年金。
不用扣什么拉奇巴刀的税。
你就存哪里钱
在当时对我来说
也是一笔巨款的
你哥现在差不多也是一笔巨款。
也还行
纯老十多万的话
工资多少
差不多吧？
所以等移清之后
然后我有一次
就专门算了一下
我那几年一共
拿了多少补贴
我发现这个数字
居然是快60万了。
我觉得这其实也是一个。
非常吓人的数字
即使说到现在的话。
每年好像都在发钱。
对
只不过咱们现在没有身份。
去拿这个钱
对
所以现在我们不是。
变成课税了吗？
当再看到新闻里面说。
政府为了应对物价上涨。
决定给非课税
就是低收人群
再发什么3万5万的时候。
我就想骂街了
因为我变成课税了。
这钱给我们关起来了。
你身份不一样了
那肯定的
对
你要知道日本政府是没钱的。
他发的所有的钱
都是从我们的钱里面。
扣出来的
对
那当时给你的钱
那不也是从其他的大税人身上。
扣出来的
那不管
反正你拿我的钱
你发钱没有我不行。
而且还有一个点
我想起来就是
当时我都不知道
就是什么是住民税。
什么是什么森林税。
什么各种各样的税。
就怎么交 交多少。
我都不知道
我也没想过
然后我就是只是
一味地去申请他的减免。
有国民年纪的减免。
保险料的减免
但是成功在社会人之后。
我发现
当时耗的这些羊毛。
就一点一点的
都交了这些税都还回去了。
对
税 还有年金
还有保险
都是按照收入的比例来交的。
上学的时候
在没有收入
所以税和年金
其实都可以做到全额减免。
然后保险料减免完了。
也就是一千多日元。
就可以享受到
国民的保险
70%报销
而且
如果你有重大疾病。
或是住院做手术的话。
它有一个高额疗养制度。
来做补充
这个高额疗养制度。
也是根据收入来划分的。
现在我们工作了以后。
我每个月光保险
就得两万块钱
是啊 谁让你挣工资了呢？
然后我现在
如果有重大疾病
或者说是需要做手术的话。
那个高额疗养那个等级。
自己费的额度也在增加。
谁让你挣工资了呢？
挣的越多 交的越多。
最恐怖的就是
每个月看那个
就是一个工资条
你就发现
扣的
所得税呀？
国家的税呀？
人税就是地方税呀？
年金保险加一块
已经占到工资的
将近三分之一了吧？
对
所以你也就会发现。
就不管工资上涨到多少。
其实到手的金额
没有太大的差别
对 这个就是最恐怖的。
对 顶多就是差个一两万块钱。
对
你是拿到手
如果差出来一两万的话。
有可能
你们的账面工资
都已经差出来3到5万了。
甚至更多了
因为你划分的等级。
是不一样的
每个扣款的比例
也是不一样
然后日本这边
最讨厌的就是公司。
还按照顶格交
对
按照上线交
你知道吧？
这个其实如果说到。
后续的养老什么的。
这其实是挺好的一个。
操作的
是
但就是对现在的生活。
其实造成了不小的压力。
对
真的就是我明明可以。
落到第一档
能省个几千块钱
一万块钱
然后给我C到高的那一档。
我就有点烦
然后因为这个事
我还特意找我们公司的。
那个事务去问过
我说这个是不是够交错了。
我是不是应该交下一档。
他说没错
他们都是按照顶格交的。
为了你们以后的
养老考虑
我说谢谢你
现在不够花装
但是有一些小公司。
其实他是按照最低标准来交的。
而且他会把工资的一部分。
做成补贴
就是手当的形式
那就是说这个手当。
是不合算在收入里面了。
对
他只按照基本工资。
来给你交这个保险。
会更低一些
这其实是
不是很人心化的地方。
而你们工资下样相反。
这其实是
对员工比较好的一个网账。
好
我谢谢的
谢谢公司
别谢了
过一周离职
所以就是说咱们以前。
就像是坐在餐桌上。
等着被分肉的那个人。
然后现在咱们就是。
分的那块肉
我们就是
人为到所为一肉
对对对
而且你就会发现
不管大家的工资是多少。
差别有多大
其实大家在生活当中的。
日常的消费什么的。
其实差别不是很大。
对
一些意识住行
吃串用度
对
其实如果是
按照之前
就是日本一直处于一个物价平稳。
然后整个社会处于。
一个通缩状态的话。
其实还好
你如果物价不涨的话。
只要你工资一点点。
往上涨的话
其实你的生活是得往上走的。
对不对
尽管它走得慢了一点。
但是问题的关键就是。
现在
日本这个物价涨的。
有点快
有点离谱
这个通胀一上来了以后。
让这些客税的人员去买单。
就很烦
因为物价上涨了以后。
政府就给低收入的人发钱。
各种应对物价上涨。
但是
咱们也没拿着
所以物价上涨
对于咱们的冲击是更大。
一方面是我工资涨的少。
一方面是物价涨的多。
就有可能
你今年工资涨的少了一点。
还赶不上物价上涨的速度呢？
这是真的
而且这是肯定的
因为
之前是
我看有一个人做了一个研究。
说他的工资
在保证每年上涨的情况下。
其实到今天来说算了一下。
实际的时候
是比之前缩出的25%的。
对
这个其实在日本的。
综艺节目里面好多次的。
都被提到过
就是莫名其妙的
还不如30年前的时候。
就是这种感觉
而且就是近30年的物价。
一直保持了
没有变化的一个
对
一个样子
就是近两年
这个物价才开始飞涨。
对
他这个社会的稳定。
也是靠这30年来。
物价不涨的来维持的。
我之前真的觉得
就是刚来的时候
因为没有什么钱
也不太舍得去花
所以买菜的时候
就会挑那些
最便宜的东西去买。
对
当时就想着
我工作了就好了
对
我当时真的是想的。
我说现在吃这些豆腐。
豆腐最便宜的东西。
那再过个35年
再过个78年
我肯定我的生活的水平。
就提上去了嘛？
对
但是万万没想到
我们过了35年
过了78年
甚至过了将近10年了。
我们的生活
还是这样
就谁能知道
谁能知道
现在出门
就还得买这些
最便宜的东西
对
但是咱们不在这哭穷。
就是不在这刻意的去。
恶化咱们现在的生活。
也确实咱们现在
相比留学的时候
生活质量会高很多了。
只是说在消费方面的话。
可能考虑的东西
其实是跟当年是一样的。
对
就是还得是追求性价比。
你不可以没有截至的。
去挥霍你挣的工资。
是
咱众类七的一都挥霍不了。
一点
咱这点钱挥霍不了。
更挥霍不了
因为之前我想的是。
过了这么多年之后。
我可能就可以
超市自由了吧？
我想吃那些水果
我可以书买就买了吧？
但发现现在
可能还不是这样的。
就是你还得去
规划一些
实惠一些
才可以
我觉得在日本
实现水果自由
有点难
你毕竟一个哈密丸。
能卖到两万日元
一个方形的西瓜
能卖到三五万的
对那种我想都不行。
我想就是
超市里面品质不错的。
然后比较好吃的牛水果。
那咱们接下来
就从生活的细节
通过衣食住行四个方面。
来带大家真气的
去感受一下
日本物价的一个变化。
虽然说是衣食住行。
但肯定得把食放前面。
这是咱们节目的传统。
也是咱们节目的一大特色。
啥都离不开吃
所以第一个肯定是得聊吃。
那聊吃咱就离不开。
大米的新闻
这个事全世界都有名了吧？
这个令和大米荒
这个去年
日本的这个大米
一度从五公斤两千日元。
包涨到五公斤四千多日元。
即使是这样了
好多超市的货价都是空的。
那个大米都没有
而且即便是有的话。
它也限购
就是一个家族只能买一袋。
对它已经价格涨了一倍多了。
就这样都买不到
然后这还不是最魔幻的。
最魔幻的就是新闻里面。
农邪的人还说今年大米获胜。
我们明年要减产
一边大家是嫌米贵买不到米。
一边说今年大米多我要减产。
就形成了一个很魔幻的一个场景。
就是有没有可能大家是买不起了呢？
农邪完全不考虑这个问题。
然后不是为了应对这个大米商场。
政府不是把这个储备米放出来了吗？
就是那个菇菇米
还有菇菇菇米
然后我听了有开玩笑的就说。
菇菇米就是两个骨子了。
是人能吃的最低品质的米。
那合着三个骨的那个米。
人都不能吃
如果是菇菇菇米
或者说菇菇菇菇米。
就是得当飼料的
就是不能让人吃的已经。
那直接喂给牛马不刚合适吗？
对啊？
现在不就放上来喂牛马了吗？
是啊？
就这个储备米
你看咱们到现在的话。
这件事已经过了大概将近小一年了吧？
89个月肯定是有了。
我到现在没在任何一家超市。
见过储备米或者菇菇米来卖。
我只是在新闻里见过。
有可能在一些地方都已经卖光了。
也说不定
有的是卖光了被抢光了。
但是我看新闻据说是。
这个菇菇米是指定机构在卖的。
而且农协在极力反对这个菇菇米。
也就是说这堆这个铜的这个物资。
其实农协不想让它被放出来。
对啊？
因为这个日本的农协是独立存在的。
所以他跟政府怎么说呢？
相对于一个各管各的。
然后政府是为了应对大米商长。
我夸夸夸放这个储备米。
然后农协那边
不行你别放你别放。
我这边米卖不出去了。
大家不要以为日本的农协只负责农产品。
日本的农协什么都干。
他有银行
他有医院
然后他还有自己的保险。
就是他什么都干
然后据说
没有任何的官方背书。
没有任何的新闻位书。
就是我听到的小道理消息。
据说是农协好像投资没股投失败了。
然后为了填补这个大窟窿。
他把这个大米的价格给炒上来了。
然后在填补这个窟窿之前。
这个米一架下不来。
因为放出来的这些米。
90%以上都在农协手里囤着的。
而且那些米商
他不敢私自的去放米。
就是怎么说呢？
农协规定一大米4000。
那么我良心
我有良心
我为了民生考虑
我这个米商
我自己给它降到2000行吗？
不行
怎么有种这个行业的一个黑社会。
对
对 就是垄断的这个。
就是所有人的定价都必须按照农协的要求。
否则到第二年不给你配合了。
那还真是小道消息。
就是据说
无从考证的一时
但是现在好就好在。
其实米价有点回落了。
对 尤其是这几个月。
超市的这些最贵的米。
好像没有到4500以上。
都在3900多组。
甚至有些米能下碳到3500了。
当然是没获得一个状态。
我们去超市这几次都看到了。
打特价的那些米
不是姑姑米
我们姑姑米根本就没见过。
就是那些正经的那些米。
打特价的3500的基本都是空的。
而且有人说
那日本的大米贵
那你买进口的米不就得了吗？
因为进口不是说便宜吗？
对 为啥呢？
为啥不吃进口的米。
因为进口米跟这边国产的米的价格。
其实差不多的
差得多的呢？
是因为太难吃了
日本有美国米
美国米确实也便宜。
但是那个难吃程度。
还不如吃姑姑米呢 我觉得。
就是当时我记得我留学的时候。
我买过
我图片一买过
Cosco这个美国大米。
当时5公斤的大米。
大概的价格是2000元左右吧？
然后Cosco的这个美国的大米呢？
就1400块钱
一下便宜四分之一呢？
我买了一单
我就争过一回
还是两回
然后那家米又给扔了。
真的
难吃到这个
是雪梨知道
我是一个特别讨厌浪费粮食的人。
难吃到老饭开始主动浪费粮食了。
已经给我难吃到
没有办法下嘴
他都不是说
好不好吃的
你都已经考虑能不能吃了。
你看这就是牛马都吃不了的私料。
对
那还不是牛马 那是准牛马。
所以呢？
有这一次教训以后。
我就宁可多花点钱。
我也绝对不吃这个美国大米。
那有朋友就得问了。
那你吃中国米啊？
对不对
中国米多少吃啊？
是
我们也知道中国米好吃。
但是呢？
你在日本见不到
因为日本会针对这个大米呢？
有一个本国的这个价格保护。
那么为了保护好本国的这个米农的这个利益。
或者说是本国的这个大米的这个产量。
或者销量的话
他就会把这个进口米的关税。
设得非常高
而且除了正常的关税以外。
他好像还有一个额外的一个税。
反正就是乱七八糟税加一几的话。
好像是
超过他的配合以外。
每一公斤就要交300多日元的一个税。
也就是说
至少这个关税能到340%或者更高。
如果只是这样了
其实还好
因为咱们国内的大米便宜。
即使说加了300% 400% 70% 500%。
你弄到日本来
跟日本米卖的一样。
加或者比日本米卖的高。
就是咱们也可以接受对不对。
但是呢？
为什么在日本看不见中国米呢？
就是因为他会通过。
特别繁杂的手续来卡中国米。
来卡这些米上
不让他进日本
曾经日本出现过一阵这个东北大米。
当时据说是对于日本米产生了很大的一个冲击。
所以就是不允许卖了。
后来
而且不光是商业渠道。
好像是在机场那边近几年也都会查得更严一些。
对
之前的话有一些同学朋友。
还可以每年过来的时候。
从机场带个一两袋。
或者两三袋大米过来。
但现在的话基本上。
一带过来
可能就会被那个小狗闻到。
然后就被开箱了
就是我不知道
现在听节目的朋友。
你们是觉得日本米好吃。
还是国产米好吃
反正我和雪梨是
特别爱吃国产米的。
尤其是东北物产大米。
我们特别爱吃国内的米。
但是我们身边的朋友。
尤其是在国内的朋友。
都说日本的米好吃。
不知道为什么？
有可能是因为我们在日本。
所以觉得国内好吃。
我们之前带过来的五肠大米。
蒸出来了以后有一种米香味。
然后米饭是那种
带着光泽的油润的那种感觉。
对那种米其实蒸出来。
就特别像是日本东班里面。
刚出过的那种感觉。
但是反而日本本地的米。
可能没有那种光泽。
对跟加着特效一样。
亮晶晶的那种感觉。
不是中华小店家里面。
一开盖啪啊一样
所以听众朋友们
你们也可以在评论区里面。
打出来
你们是觉得日本的米好吃。
还是国内的米好吃。
好吧？
我记得我之前在网上。
还看到过就是有些有客。
从国内过来的时候。
特地从日本这边
打包了一两公斤的小袋的米。
回国吃
对这个我也听说了。
对
尤其是在国内
特别爱吃制料的
然后他们就会说
我当时在哪个店里面。
吃的那个米
他们说是从日本进口的大米。
对对对
特别好吃
我特地这回来
带一袋回去尝尝
我说啊？
我说啥大米
然后我一看
这不就是咱家
给我卖的大米吗？
我说就啥好吃
可能令你太近了
有可能有可能
但是好
就说日本的大米
它是比较的
粘性可能比较高
然后水分可能大一些。
你说这个好像日本。
它是不是大米
大米还分什么品种。
对没错
我最早的时候
我挑大米
是要挑产地跟品种的。
比如说新鲜
或者北海道的米
然后这个
古希哈利就是那个月光。
那个米不是很有名吗？
我一般都会挑那个米吃。
但是后来
随着这个米价越来越高。
就你一眼看着
它从最开始的一千九。
涨到四千多块钱
我就不挑这些产地了。
挑便宜是吧？
都便宜的
什么便宜吃什么？
但是虽然说
现在这个大米
涨价涨的有点凶
虽然说有一些回路。
但是呢？
依旧相比之前
涨了特别多了
那其实
我觉得对于咱们家还好。
不是说我跟雪梨吃米少。
是因为我们家的米呢？
都是每年在这个
故乡大税上买的
这个故乡大税是什么呢？
我们在这里给
听了朋友们简单解释一下。
就是说
我们在日本生活
不是要交税吗？
那么这笔钱呢？
你交了可能就是交了。
那如果说
你利用这个日本的。
这个故乡大税这个制度的话。
你就可以把你这部分税钱。
当做一笔购物额度。
来在这个故乡大税的。
专门的网站上去消费。
不管你的额度是多少钱。
你自己只需要
掏2000日元的这个。
算是进厂费吧？
那么你消费的这个额度。
在第二年
就可以用来
减免你的税
所以就是变相的
结税了吧？
就是变相的用税
换了一点东西吧？
大家可能听到这去的。
哎 这还不错对不对。
假如说我有10万块钱的税。
我这10万块钱交脸交了。
但是现在我可以买10万块钱的东西。
对不对 明年还能抵10万块钱的税。
但是呢？
大家有所不知
就是这个
故乡大税的这个网站吧？
它里面的东西的价格。
基本上都是市面价格的3倍。
就是假如说
一辆大米5公斤
差不多要4000日元。
那么在这个网站上。
5公斤就是1万
那么其他的东西
也是类似于这样
你在上面可以买到各地的农产品。
什么水果呀？
肉呀？
海鲜呀？
但是价格都要比市方的。
要贵将近3倍
但是呢？
你现在用的是
你本来要交的这个税钱。
就是虽然说它贵
但是多少能换点东西回来吧？
总比直接扔了墙嘛？
总比直接交给国家墙吧？
所以呢？
我跟雪梨
我们每年就用那个故乡大税。
来换这么二三十公斤的大米。
就是够我们家能吃个半年。
大半年吧？
因为感觉大米
应该是这些产品里面。
升价比最高的
对
因为其他的我觉得。
议价太严重了
就是没有必要在市场上。
花这个钱
是
两万块钱买一盒牛肉。
里面四片
我就想
所以会看两千块钱。
值不值得买
这个网站上的一些东西。
那你就会发现
大米其实是这里面。
性价比最高的
对
我们身边的朋友
好多也是买大米的。
我就记得
有一个同事
特别离谱
他一次性买了六十公斤大米。
那你要这么一算的话。
其实他年收挺高的。
对
人家是个人事业主。
人家收入肯定高
但是你要买六十公斤。
然后他会来问他
我说你一次性买六十公斤。
你们家往哪搁
咱都不是说
你能不能吃完
你们家往哪搁
六十公斤
那可是六十公斤
他说
我说六十公斤
你全放桌的底下吗？
他说不是
就是他买的时候
会设置成分三次寄送。
他说我隔三四个月。
让他寄送一次
六十公斤分批分次的送。
每一次送的米
其实都是在送之前。
刚经好的
我说这合适
就是一直能吃上新鲜米。
这一年
然后回来
我跟雪梨也说
咱们是不是也能一次性。
多买点
然后分批分次的送。
然后我跟雪梨
核算了一下
我们俩的
雇乡纳税的这个额度。
好像又不着
买不起六十公斤大米。
我们俩的税还远没到那个程度。
你们说人家挣得太多了。
对
我们俩为什么买二公斤呢？
是因为我们的额度。
只能买二公斤
二公斤那你没有必要。
分批分次送
那么除了大米以外。
什么面 油
其实也都在涨价
而且涨价也都是
翻发着在涨
对
你包括像什么肉 蔬菜。
然后还有水果
对
蔬菜之前的话
是7999这样的价格。
对
然后现在的话都得是199299。
其实蔬菜还好
因为蔬菜水果的话。
受季节性影响比较大。
你就赶上秋天的时候。
就是菜还是挺便宜的。
咱们在超市里面
还能是能买到这个几十块钱。
一把的菜
对 但是你买的时候。
就得挑超市了
你不能说是所有的。
超市都是这个价格。
对
就得去自己去找一下才行。
冬天的话它本来就很贵。
水果和蔬菜
所以其实即使它长在家里。
我们依然是会选择性忽视的。
我们会挑便宜的买的。
或者打折的
对
然后或者买一些冷冻的蔬菜。
或者说是
西红柿罐头这样的。
比较方便保存的东西。
其实我觉得这个冷冻蔬菜。
有时候还特别方便的。
非常方便
如果说是伊尔菜的话。
可能冷冻的不太好保存。
但是那种根净类的。
真的非常好
叫什么西兰花
那个土豆或者茄子。
最关键的有一些这样土豆茄子。
它都是炸好的切块的。
这个很方便的
所以你买点那个青椒。
回来就直接可以炒第三仙汁。
特别方便
包括我之前还会买一些。
什么小松菜
或者说是剥菜的这样冷冻的。
它都会保存时间会长一些。
而且那个在做的时候。
其实口感上
没有什么特别大的差别。
对 因为毕竟都有煮熟的吃吗？
尤其是煮汤的时候。
那个更没有什么差别。
对 就是说
如果你不追求
一个极致的新鲜的程度的话。
这些冷冻的蔬菜
反而是又便宜
然后保存时间又可以更长一些的。
就特别适合这种打工的牛马吃。
这就比较考验
我们家那个冰箱的冷冻。
对 冰箱的冷冻的这个空间了。
就是以至于
我跟谁留们俩商量。
要不要直接买一个冰柜。
就无复次的动心
就是这个冰箱我觉得很奇怪。
冰箱是挺大的
但是为什么冷冻的这个区间。
就这么小呢？
我觉得还是跟这个日本的。
就是冰箱的
设计的空间结构有关系。
咱们国内的话
不能说55开吧？
至少也差不多吧？
就是冷冻和冷藏
然后我们家这个冰箱。
就虽然说它挺大的。
但是呢 它分了三块。
上下都是冷藏
中间那一点是冷冻。
对 下面那个冷藏。
人家叫做保鲜
就是一些
放水果啊什么的
新鲜的水果蔬菜
该放的地方
可能因为我们穷
我们吃不清
这些东西也这样
就只能买冷冻
好惨
就是冰箱跟上了
这个生活品质
但是我们没跟上
应该说我们拖了冰箱的后腿。
对
然后像一些肉蛋奶。
也都是从99、199。
长到29、999。
也都是在分费的涨价。
尤其这个鸡蛋
我就特别想吐槽一下这个鸡蛋。
当时上学的时候
我们买这个鸡蛋
10个大概也就100来个钱。
最便宜的有79、99的。
对 但是那个的话。
赛子就小了
日本那边买一盒鸡蛋。
其实它大小的差不多的。
有S赛子的
或者说是M赛子
或者A路赛子的
其实是这样
我当时在脑子里面换身人臂。
你想 10个鸡蛋。
100块钱
就是6块钱
6块钱
6块钱10的
其实当时跟北京的物价。
是一样的
6毛钱一个
对
然后现在10个鸡蛋。
要卖到299、399。
品质好一点
有499
对
然后换算成人民币。
20多块钱
10个鸡蛋
便宜的也得13、15块。
然后现在背将近2个钱一个。
甚至我们之前去的一个物产店。
他之前一直在卖茶叶蛋。
后来鸡蛋价格涨的。
他都卖不起了
他都不卖了
他把锅都收起来了。
我们当时去那个物产店。
两个茶叶蛋是88。
88的话也就是和3块多钱。
还好对不对
跟国内价格也差不多了。
国内现在的茶叶蛋。
估计都两个钱一个了吧？
然后我们每次去
都得买45个
然后我们近两个月就发现。
那个锅没了
人不卖了
然后问了一下老板说。
我们特别喜欢吃银茶叶蛋。
你怎么不卖的
他说
这个之后考虑考虑吧？
对
他们说的是没时间做。
但是我跟雪梨都觉得。
就是因为他卖不起了。
对 就是合不上成本了。
现在都已经这么贵了。
对
然后之前还一直说。
那个鸡蛋和鸡油涨价。
是因为有情流感
情流感一直情流感。
情流感没走过
你知道吗？
我之前还数过
我说一年至少得有。
三次情流感
结果这情流感一直没走。
然后鸡蛋价格就一直在上升。
一直马上涨
一直再也没有降下来过。
你就感觉全世界
任何一个地方的情流感。
日本鸡蛋都会涨价。
然后水果也是
水果其实在日本
本身就是一个比较贵的东西。
即使在之前
我们也不是处于一个水果。
自由的状态
然后现在物价一涨。
以前吃不起的东西。
现在更吃不起了
以前稍微能吃得起的东西。
现在都得思考一下。
以前是觉得它贵
但是摇摇牙居然能买。
现在是摇摇牙
把牙摇碎了
都觉得就放哪吧？
对
以前上学的时候
觉得西瓜按照当时的汇率。
换成人民币
大概100多块钱。
一个已经算是很贵了。
已经很离谱了
你各国内的话
一个季节应该都能买个。
五六额吧？
对
然后我们现在发现。
即使汇率降了
按照现在的汇率
一个西瓜
也要将近200多人币。
300多人币
我们就直接放弃了。
所以我们俩现在买西瓜。
基本上都是
到超市里面看看
有没有那种盒装的。
或者说是
大主要的西瓜来挑而吃。
除了超市以外
我们在外面吃饭
价格也是在上涨的。
而且伴随着价格的上涨。
这个尺寸还有缩水。
这个量还有减少
我觉得它就是在悄悄涨价。
然后为了让你不要那么难受。
然后分量就变小了。
但是还是维持了
原来的价格
你想大米
或者油
我一下给你涨2%。
你不吃不行
对不对
这是生活的刚许
你离了这个你活不了。
所以涨500%
你该买得买
它就肆无奸的涨
但是外面那些
饮食店不一样
如果你一次性
摆一个300多的东西。
涨到了700多
那肯定大家都不去买了。
因为我外面吃不起。
我家做行不行
我能不能吃点便宜呢？
它有屏替了
好找了吗？
所以商家为了
不让你体感上这么有冲击性。
就会在稍微涨价的同时。
降低一点分量
变相其实就是
涨了两倍的价格
对
其实都是一样
最典型的就是卖当劳。
卖当劳其实也是我想说的一个。
卖当劳涨几回价了。
这两年的话
应该是
我知道的
好像就已经调了有三回价了吧？
就是每一次都是20元。
30元 50元这样子的威涨。
对
它的牛肉的涨了最多的。
每一次的涨50元。
然后不仅它涨价
你发现酒吧那个尺寸。
越来越小了
它已经不叫巨无霸了。
它叫小无霸
巨小无霸
我记得以前酒吧最便宜的时候。
应该是360一个。
而且尺寸要比这个大。
对
然后现在是480。
单品是480
对
你如果是要点一个套餐的话。
就要780
如果是变成大号的话。
就800多了
对
你看
360涨到480。
它涨了120
它尺寸又减少了两圈。
礼拜礼不就涨了百分之百吗？
对吧？
就是以前的时候
一个酒吧的一个大号套餐。
基本上就保了
然后现在我就发现。
就是吃一个酒吧的感觉。
就像我吃了一个
卖香鱼的那种感觉一样。
我还能再吃一个
还能再吃一个
也不是说是到了
非常保的程度
对
就是即使再吃一个。
怎么说保了
但是不到一撑的那种状态。
对
就是那样
然后你说到这个
有一个最烦的就是。
从今年2月份开始。
日本麦当劳的这个。
十趴七锦
就是国内的这个麦辣鸡。
要下架了
说到这个麦辣鸡
其实是我最不能接受的。
因为日本的麦当劳对我来说。
好吃的就两款
一个是酒吧？
还有一个就是这个麦辣鸡。
嗯
我也是特别爱吃麦辣鸡。
但是我还爱吃这个麦香鱼。
你现在好歹还有得选。
不是麦香鱼涨架了。
都现在已经400了一颗。
有道理
我喜欢吃这个麦辣鸡。
它是这个麦当劳里面。
最便宜的四个其中之一。
它现在这个四个最便宜的。
现在已经下架了两个了。
也就是最好吃的两个。
都已经下架了
而且现在已经不是最便宜的四个了。
它现在最便宜的
只剩下那个
Hamburger。
对
其他的都已经200网上了。
我觉得以前是出去玩的时候。
我不太想吃
景点那些饭嘛？
它比较贵
所以我就会买四个麦辣鸡。
然后两个两个的吃。
就是性价比非常高。
而且能吃饱的那种。
对
然后它又很好吃
我觉得这个简直是支撑了。
我之前的留学生活的。
非常重要的一部分。
结果它现在就已经没了。
现在有的只剩下那个。
麦香鸡还是有的
但是这个麦辣鸡已经没了。
所以现在我就发现。
不管是超市还是外市。
这个价格都在翻倍的上涨。
所以我们两个的伙食费。
也在翻倍的涨
我觉得之前上学的时候。
我一个人的伙食费。
最便宜的一个月
也就是一万块钱
加上外市的话
可能也就是
一万出头不到两万的样子。
然后就想说
现在生活好了
然后开始挣钱了
一个人一个月
三万的预算
应该是够了
两个人不就是六万块吗？
我心想六万块钱
三千多
你吃什么一个也不够吃。
那么最开始的时候。
咱俩是够的
对
最开始的时候
我们到月底甚至还有点富裕。
是
但是尤其到二五年。
我们明显发现
这个生活费控制不住了。
不管你怎么去省
接着说我们经常去买菜。
然后自己在家做
我们每个月的活费。
也得到七万
如果说外市多一点的话。
那么这个月就得奔着。
八万甚至九万去了。
对 或者说有一些。
宴请朋友这样的场合的话。
而且说到这个
宴请朋友的城门
也带急剧增加
真的
以前咱们出去吃一顿饭。
像去那个保利多麦。
之前咱们推荐过的这个居酒屋。
四个人的话
也就吃个八千多
现在的话
咱们前两天去的那个。
也是四个人
吃了一万七千多
因为保利多麦
它也涨价了
而且它这个涨价
其实都是很隐形的。
因为每一个小东西。
它的价格
你看着它其实不贵。
但是点一圈下来
你就会发现
比以前可能要很方了。
对
你包括在超市买东西也是。
之前同样的
三千块钱的东西
现在你花六千块钱。
才可以买到
之前同样的这些量了。
对
而且你买了以后
有可能在里面的东西。
还缩水了
比如一袋原来给你。
八个产
先给你六个了那种。
就是现在我就觉得。
不仅吃的
跟以前没有什么变化。
支出其实反而还是更多了。
对
所以这工资涨了
相当于没涨
有可能还降工资了。
对
那除了吃
这个住
其实也是一个大问题。
日本的这个房价
尤其是东京的这个房价。
可能也在国内
铺了名了吧？
最近两年
据前一阵的这个新闻。
说是东京的这个新房的这个均价。
已经突破一亿日元了。
这个突破一亿日元。
可能换算成人币的话。
还不是这么恐怖
你想一亿日元的话。
不也就是按照五来算的话。
也就是五百万吗？
这个在北京
也很正常
对不对
很正常对不对
而且北京均价
肯定是早就过五百万了。
你家那块的多少钱了。
是
对吧？
但是这个事咱不能这么算。
咱得看看之前的多少钱。
我们刚来那会
在东京
如果买一套
相对来说不错的这个公寓的话。
可能也就是五千万左右吧？
但是到了现在
已经翻了一倍了
你看在国内的话
其实前几年
就是房地产市场比较热的时候。
翻一倍的这个情况。
也是正常的
但是同时
大家的收入也在往上走呀？
是的
但是日本是房价涨了一倍。
工资份不一味变
物价也不涨了一倍。
而且你会发现
它不是说
一直在经历上涨这个阶段。
它是经过了泡沫破灭了之后。
然后持续平稳了三十多年。
现在又开始
现在往上涨了
对 往上涨价了
而且涨得特别快
短短的这么？
三到五年之内
就一下涨了百分之百。
你要知道
它前面三十年就没变过。
这个房间
还是挺吓人的
上一次这么高
还是泡沫的时候
对
以至于现在
我们看很多日本的节目。
采访日本的老百姓。
都说买不起房子了。
或者说是拿着手里贴钱。
买不到一个能住的。
舒服的房子了
对 所以很多人就会往。
一都三线的
一些郊区的地方去跑。
就导致现在
我们家不是在签业吗？
签业这个房价
也是水涨穿高
我们紧着躲远点东京。
还是没躲开房价
上涨带来的影响
对 但是这边的话。
就相对涨的稍微慢一些。
然后幅度小一些
涨一两千万这样子。
但是相对于新房
新房翻倍的涨
这个二手房
其实涨的幅度
还是处在一个
相对能接受的一个区间。
所以我跟雪梨看房子。
现在就是
几乎都在看二手房。
对 新房涨价的幅度。
实在是超过了
我们能够接受的范围了。
对 我估计咱们再晚。
那么你两天买到
有可能二手房都买不起了。
至少现在看的话
其实日本的房价
没有一个下跌的一个趋势。
或者没有一个下跌的信号在。
更何况现在汇率一低了以后。
全世界的炒房客
都跑到东京来炒房。
那新房出来都是秒煤的那种。
在网上还建过很多的帖子。
就是在东京都内
有很多套房产的人。
多的有那种二耳朵套的。
他那个资产蹭了一下就升值了。
对 就是这东西别低。
就是这个
摆房价一炒上去了以后。
老百姓跟着遭罪
普通老百姓
你根本就买不起房子了。
而且炒房摆房子
炒上去了以后
你发现不仅是买房。
咱们租房的房租也在往上涨。
日本这边租房是两年一千的。
然后现在有很多都内的一些房子。
在更新的时候
都在给你涨房租
对 我那个房子就是。
去年我今天要通知的时候。
他说他要涨四千块钱。
但是我们言辞拒绝了。
不同意
对 最开始的时候。
我也没想到说这事就能成。
然后当时也就是看。
网上有人有这个经验。
报了那种税式的态度。
然后打了那个电话。
说不好意思 我不接受。
然后没想到最后
这事还真成了
但其实人家也不是说。
当时马上就同意了。
人家虽然当时没有问。
你为什么不接受
但是他直接说
那涨四千不行
那涨一千行不行
我说我考虑考虑
然后第二天跟他说。
不行
我不接受 还是不接受。
然后你就说
那就不涨了
但其实如果你当时。
直接跟他说
涨一千我也不接受。
有可能当时他就同意了。
对 但我现在
还是要给对方一个抬脚。
还得缓冲一下 是吧？
有一个接受的一个过程。
对 然后这样的话。
管理公司还是按照。
原来的价格
给我继续在许愿了。
这个也是我觉得
法律制度都比较偏向。
租客的地方
才能享受到的这种。
不能说便宜吧？
只能说是这种好事。
就是一个正常的权益。
租客该有的一个权益。
保证到我们这个权益。
但是如果说
你不知道这个事情的话。
那肯定你就争取不到。
你该有的这个权益。
有可能就是
在国内做房租习惯了。
来这边做的
你长房租就长房租。
对 那就觉得很正常的事情。
而且这还人提前通知你。
但这边如果你要是。
实在不接受
然后它实在要长的话。
那你其实也可以跟房东。
去索要就是搬家的一些赔偿。
对 对 对
都是你合法合理的这样的权益。
这不之前有一个新闻。
说有一个中国这个房东。
忽然把这个房租提高了两倍。
还上新闻了吗？
那个我也看到了 对吧？
它就是一个中国房东。
可它可能就是按照。
中国人的这个思想去做事。
在日本就行不通了。
好像最后打官司
也是判那个房东输了。
就好像这个房东
已经违法了是怎么样的吧？
反正挺严重的
所以其实我们在国外生活。
那么入乡随俗
还是要按照当地的一个行为模式。
去生活的
不管你在哪
尽量都不要跟大环境对着来。
其实我觉得他们
现在普遍的一个价格的上涨。
对于那帮刚毕业的学生。
甭管是日本人
还是外国人
就更加不友好的
对 尤其是现在的话。
在东京的东内
如果你需要找一个。
在十万以内的房子的话。
基本是没有了
像以前的话
咱们要是租一个1K。
或者One Room。
就是你们能在小红书上。
或者各种摄像软件上。
能看到的
就是标准榴子开局。
地人区的那种小公寓。
那种特别小的公寓。
二十多平的
那么以前的话
可能六七万块钱
最便宜的时候
应该是这个价格
对吧 差不多也能租下来了。
但是现在
如果你找一个都内。
位置比较好的
比如说什么上野
或者说池带
这种地方的话
基本十万块钱你就做不到了。
那个地方其实都得十三四万了。
十万的话是平均在。
就是山手线以内
或者说中间一些地方。
都已经没有这个价格了。
稍微便宜一点了
比如说你住到这个赤鱼。
或者说是窗口
其实赤鱼还是比较方便。
金屏东北
然后窗口就是属于奇遇县了。
那一块的房子的话。
也得要可八九万了。
那么这样的话
对于刚步入社会的学生。
或者说是刚来日本的留学生。
其实压力会变大的。
虽然我们也在租房。
但是好在我们租的比较早。
我们还可以有权利。
或者说可以去应对。
这个房租涨价
但是刚来的人
是真的没有办法
只能是应着了
对 刚来的话
你的房租
肯定会超过
你的收入三分之一的。
而且还有一个最大的问题。
就是日本倒霉房
不是有一个前期料金吗？
你房租上涨了
你前期的费用肯定要上涨。
因为它的压金也好。
中介费也好
还是说礼金也好
都是按照几倍的房租来算的。
甭管是一倍
还是两倍
还是零点五倍
那么你房租涨了
你同样的
你前期的料金也涨了。
而且前期的这些料金。
打包一算的话
基本都是在房租的。
五倍左右的价格
对 差不多吧？
也就是说
如果你这个房子
是八万块钱的话
那么你第一次交的钱。
应该是在四十万上下。
是 我这个房子不就是。
加上停车费
管理费不一共八万。
我前期不就交了四十来万。
那现在如果在涨价的话。
那更多了
打包下来的价格
奔着五十去了
那你以为房子涨价了。
就完了吗？
并没有
你住在这个房子里的成本。
也在上升
它水电煤也在涨
而且日本这个水
它是分上下水道去收费的。
对对对
它分两笔钱
你就上水道是一笔钱。
下水道是一笔钱
对
而且上下水道
分别它有自己的基础料金。
也就是说
你一个月
如果一吨水都不用的话。
它也是要收费的
是的
但是东京都民
在夏天的时候
不是有几个月的
是上水道减免
下水道减免
然后好像电费
好像是不是也有
我记得
去年好像有电费的。
高温的补贴
反正东京都民
虽然说他们的房租。
会贵一些
然后房子小一些
但是他们
每年的福利
确实要比我们高很多。
就是因为他们的支支。
会比咱们多一些
所以会有一些
比较少的补贴
东京都好像去年
发了好几次钱了
对
然后再加上补贴
据我们朋友说
育儿补贴也不一样。
是的
育儿补贴东京都的力度。
是最大
而且还有一个就是。
在东京都买这个
新能源车
电车
它的补贴是最多的。
所以有很多人说
如果需要生孩子的话。
你的地址
还是要迁到东京都。
这样的话
什么育儿福利
育儿手当
这个是最多的
对
但是迁到东京都
那你得在东京都里面有房。
咱们就可以在郊区里。
买一个大房子
然后在东京都里面。
租一个特别小的房子。
咱们不为了住
因为咱们通勤的话。
其实一度三现的通勤。
都还挺方便的
或者还有一个
咱们去找一个朋友。
挂到他们家
是
但是谁住在东京都那样。
咱们的朋友
好像都正在齐
你说的有道理
咱们住在东京都的朋友。
没有了
有也即将没有
没即将我搬走了
反正
可见咱们的朋友圈。
都不是很富裕的
你就可见东京都里面。
这些房子有多贵
我觉得他各种各样的。
福利补贴
也是在防止大家往外跑。
就给你这些诱惑
勾住了你别往外跑。
我行政一年三五万。
他也称不上是一个诱惑。
但是你育儿补贴高。
对吧 你一生孩子。
你得考虑了
是 但是你孩子的。
其他的成本
那肯定是很高的
你跟这些育儿补贴。
现在这些补贴比的话。
怎么说
就是有东西没有墙。
只是现在住在东京的话。
生活成本更高一些。
对的
我们不是住在千叶吗？
那么住的稍微偏一点。
所以我们除了房子的问题。
就会多一个问题
就是停车和养车的问题。
住在东京都
当然不需要考虑这个问题了。
因为东京都养不起车。
是 东京都的一个停车位的车位费。
恨不得要比我房租费还贵。
我们住在东京的朋友们。
跟我们说
一个东京的车位
一个月要4万日元。
他那个价格
应该还算是便宜的吧？
我觉得他那个价格。
是比较典型的价格。
就是在东京的
居民区或者团地
大概都是这个价格。
三四万块钱
所以他跟我说
一个月4万块钱
我跟他说我房租一个月7万。
我连车再房一个月8万。
然后朋友破房了
差距就是这么大
而且说回来
如果住在东京的话。
确实好像
养车也没有什么太大的必要。
因为东京出行
确设也很方便
是 这也要涨价了。
电车也要涨价的朋友们。
我真的离除了
电车
多少年没涨价了
很多 很多年
我都不知道
上一次涨价什么时候了。
好像在涨过价吗？
涨过
涨过 从我有记以来。
反正也是得有个
20年没有涨过了吧？
就是没有听说过
他好像涨价了这个新闻。
对 就是很新鲜
包括这个公交
也是在涨价的
所以哪怕住在
都内的朋友没有车。
但是
JR 电车
其他这些公共交通。
费用也是在涨的
也是在涨的
但是咱们也得做公共交通。
所以咱们跑不开这个。
但是咱们有额外多了。
一个养车停车的问题。
因为我们保不齐
有的时候会开车去都内。
所以就发现停车的费用。
也是水涨船高
就是怎么说
我感觉这都是房价给弄起来的。
就是房价炒上来了。
所以地涨钱了
那么地涨钱了以后。
停车厂也就涨钱了。
因为停车那块地涨钱了。
所以停车费也变贵了。
然后我之前还扒那个。
谷歌地图之前
几百年前的一个照片。
和现在的照片
我对比了一下
就是以前有最大料金的。
一些停车厂
现在好多都没有上线了。
就是你停多少时间。
就是按照时间累加呗。
对
然后包括它这个小时的单价。
也翻倍了
比如说以前一天
最大是900日元。
现在的话
一是没有最大料金。
二是这个
小时的单价
变成了12分钟400。
或者12分钟500这样的价格。
但是我和雪梨
我们现在在都内各个站点。
比如说什么驰带
上野
新宿
都有我们已经标记好的。
相对便宜的停车厂。
对
我们出门就有一大任务。
就是寻找一些比较便宜的停车厂。
然后把它标记下来。
对
以后去这个地方
只停这个停车厂
而且去这些停车厂的时候。
还不能说只标记一个。
因为有些停车厂是。
周一到周六一个价格。
周日会贵
有一些停车厂则相反。
对 周日最便宜
但你说是最便宜
但其实一天的价格的话。
最大也是1600-2000之间。
相比之前肯定是要贵的。
但是只是说
现在在你一片里面。
算是最便宜的
是的
所以我们收藏了很多。
这些便宜的停车厂。
如果有需要的朋友们。
你们可以在评论区里面打出来。
或者说家庭我去
就像今天我去
爱跳我俩
然后我俩把这个地图发给你们。
好吧？
首先它得有一辆车。
会有的
你相信咱们的听众里面。
肯定有钱人很多的。
不是 其次它身后在东京。
再其次它的有价超。
肯定有
但是虽然说停车贵了。
这个油价我觉得还可以。
之前是油价确实比较贵。
但是最近这么一两个月。
这个在行税率一失失以后。
这个油价又回归到了。
一个比较便宜的一个状态。
是眼看它从16级。
然后现在已经降到13级了。
这个怎么？
大概折扣成币的话就是。
6块多吧？
现在应该是
对 差不多6块多。
便宜的地方可能还不到6块。
咱们平常加枯速口游。
基本上就是最便宜的。
133日元
133日元的话
现在就6块来钱
甚至一度要变得比水都便宜了。
因为水涨价了
水现在在便利店
和那个自贩机应该是140以上。
我觉得油价比过那片。
但是停车的话
是不是北京也差不多。
北京的话停车费
应该是一个小时
在10到20块之间吧？
10到20块
那还行
一小时也就200 400。
对 但是它没有上线。
就是你停的越久
它不就是越贵吗？
那确实
所以如果要是去山场周边。
或者是比较繁华的一些地区的话。
你要是真正停7 8个小时。
怎么也都得100多 200块钱。
那确实够贵的
所以其实我觉得在北京停车。
也是得找一些比较便宜的单价。
那种停车场
或者是小区的那种。
不要钱的停车位
但是现在好的小区也不让进了。
所以很难受
是 那咱们现在石柱形都说完了。
就剩这个1了
为什么要把1放最后呢？
是因为1对我们来说。
我觉得最不重要吧？
我和雪梨
我们两个其实
注意力和观众点
都没在这个衣服上。
都在吃上了
我觉得其实对你来说。
1就是只要不裸着就行。
能遮身避体就可以了。
你恨不得从外边
找一张什么皮子给你衣裹。
你都不用买衣服
我现在的衣服基本上都是。
我当年毕业的时候。
从基尤离职之前
用这个社员折扣去买的。
然后你会发现
这些衣服到现在
有的就穿不了了
不是有的穿不了了。
是都穿不了了
有的是已经穿破了的了。
穿旧了的
所以现在我们两个会发现。
如果还需要买衣服的话。
大多数
也都是在优衣裤
或者基尤去买
我本来想的是
我夺工作这么多年了。
好歹去优衣裤买衣服。
我还去基尤买衣服吗？
因为基尤的定位
要比优衣裤要低的。
它的价格要低的
而且它那个优衣裤的品质。
会比基尤会更稳定好一些。
然后我们前一阵去买衣服。
我就发现
我们好像优衣裤的衣服。
买不起
对了
那一条裤的话
品质好一些的
一条要五千
当时我毕业的时候。
基尤的一个衬衣
是1499
或者1999
然后优衣裤的衬衣。
也不过就是1999。
或者说是2499。
然后这一次咱们去买衣服。
我发现
一个衬衣要3999。
一条就是那种基本款的牛仔裤。
要五千块钱
说实话
就是如果是
六千日元的价格
换成人民币的话
三百块一条裤的
其实也还好
在国内的优衣裤
也差不多
但是呢？
就是把这个六千
放在这个价格牌上的时候。
你会觉得它特别故障。
对
而且因为你知道
之前是多少钱
所以就觉得这个价格。
你更不想买
最要命的就是这个。
之前知道多少钱
是因为你一定有一个价格。
矛定了
就是在我的意识里面。
已经认定了
牛仔裤这个基本款的这种东西。
就应该是
两三千块钱
对
它就该值这么多钱。
它也就值这么多钱。
如果是四千以上
你可能就觉得
没必要了
你会觉得
不是说优衣裤买不起。
而是你GU更有性价比。
对
但是你说这个GU有性价比。
现在GU的价格
就是当年我看的优衣裤的价格。
所以我们才会一直在买GU。
对
是因为这个价格
让我们觉得
它该值这么多钱
但是它要再长点
我也觉得不值了
那你就没有衣服可买了。
对
你说到这个
其实我想起来
日本其实这几年
网购也兴起
这个衣物的购物平台。
也是有很多
比如说比较出名的。
国内的那个牌叫吸音。
吸音现在是
席卷全球
可以说是
是吗？
我以为它是日本限定理的牌子。
没有 全球特别火。
就是它这个线上产品。
就是种类非常丰富。
然后做的它很便宜。
就跟那个拼多多那种感觉是的。
对
但是它没有男装
我说呢？
怎么没有男的去投稿。
对
然后除了这个新之外。
还有几个
可能是当地的牌子。
一个叫JRL
然后还有一个叫走走趟。
好像也是女装的
一个限定品牌吧？
就是他们都有自己的APP。
然后直接在网上去。
购物就可以
对
就是很方便
价格的话
其实跟淘宝仙价格。
都差不太多
一件普通的衣服
也就是一两千
导尔松和内进的货。
或者说三千块钱
但是品质的话
肯定就是比较一般般的那种。
对
他们主打一个快销品吗？
但是这个设计
真的是非常好看
然后除了这些
评价品牌之外
如果是想买一些
比较好看的那种
日式小裙子的话
就会选择
那个叫
SNIDER
就是非常有名的
一个日本的女装
然后在国内有很多。
代购在买这个牌子。
很好看
但是就是比较贵
一件可能是
一万到两万日元左右。
现在不贵了
现在有一裤
一条牛点裤都五千了。
你的一万就不贵了。
不是 你想的
就是一件衣服
怎么也要卖个五六百。
或者说是一千
确实还是有点贵的。
然后
偶尔也会买一些
就是ZARA HM这样的。
就是国际的这种品牌。
HM我感觉
它的品质太辣
对
也就是偶尔回去逛一逛。
但是你说了这么多。
为什么都是女装
没有一个男装
男装
如果是你买衣服
基本上可能只能去。
有一股自由
然后除了这些
购物品牌
还有这些品牌之外。
我有些衣服
也会在淘宝上面买。
199包邮是吧？
对
一是因为
现在很方便
直接就出了
只有日本这样的活动。
二是因为
上面的款式
就是很丰富
可以选自己喜欢的。
然后就是因为
我这一年
确实好像也没有
什么衣服的需求
是
你的衣服
你妈都给你买了
每次回国
都得带一大堆衣服过来。
我也不想让他买
没办法
这是来自妈妈的爱。
但是我发现
就是淘宝上
你买衣服就很困难。
对
因为我现在的体型。
在淘宝上买衣服
比较困难
以前的话还好
还有就是
它这个版型
和它的这个size。
不是很标准
所以你没发现
我买的衣服
都是在一家店买的。
对
咱们现在身上的
后睡衣
这两年的睡衣
都是在那一家店买的。
就是淡繁认准了一个店。
就可了一个店
可就是好
也不是
就是因为
你知道了那个店的size了。
对
那个店的尺寸
或者说那个店的品控。
对
因为你没有这个时间。
经历
再去挑选一个合适的店。
因为在国内的话
你不合适你就退了。
一个是有运费显
但是在日本的话
基本上就是一吹子买。
买的就买了
不合适就不合适了。
你要像去年我买的。
一个雪服一样
就不还在那扔着
没地处理的
所以我感觉就是在淘宝上。
给你挑衣服
是一件非常花时间。
经历的事
而且我也不用在淘宝上。
挑衣服
我觉得既有就可以完全满足。
我的要求了
所以就会更加体现出了。
自由对你的重要性。
对
所以差不多
你看衣食住行
咱现在就都聊完了。
那么除了这些以外。
还有一个
就是日本针对于
外国人的政策变化。
其实尤其是中国人了。
首先就是说
这个签证更新的
这个手续费
我们在以前
如果更新签证
是4000日元的一个手续费。
那如果你要换拥住的话。
是8000日元
但是现在涨到了
签证更新是6000。
然后变成拥住是1万了。
那么这还不是最过分的。
最过分的是
现在日本他们居然。
想要摆这个签证更新的。
手续费涨到3万到10万。
我第一次看到新闻。
我发现他有涨到10万的时候。
我整个人是傻的
我说日本政府是不是穷疯了。
就是你们没发现
不管是物价也好
还是现在手续费也好。
他们涨价都是成倍成倍涨。
甚至你像签证更新的手续费。
这已经是涨过一次的情况下。
又涨了10倍
你就感觉他们是
真不拿人当人
没有
他们是不拿外国人当人。
可能就是觉得
来日本的这些外国人。
是太多了
然后以此说一个门槛。
这样的话
一些或是摸鱼的人。
或者说不想在日本待着的人。
就望而却步了
就回家了
而且不仅是这手续费涨了。
据说是
拥住权的规定也要更新。
就是以前
在日本拿了拥住以后。
基本上就相当于是。
搬来日本公民了
也不会再查你什么东西了。
就是到了期间
去更新一下
再留卡就可以了
但是现在
据说是要查得比较严了。
说是
如果你在拥住期间内。
不按时交税也好
不交税保也好
那么在更新的时候。
可能会面临
拒签的情况
或者说是把你拥住取消的情况。
反正感觉就是
方方面面对于外国人的政策。
都在收紧
而且我觉得他这个。
就是长到3万
或者10万
好像像一个
就是烟雾弹一样
先给你一个大的
是吧？
后面跟你说
我就长到2万
或者长到5万
对
你心里面就好接受一点。
心理战术
最好就是不长
如果这个事最后流产。
还是比较好的
现在还是在讨论中。
对
反正我是觉得
应该是大概率会长。
但是会长得少一些。
但是这个审查
确实
现在也是非常费时间的一件事。
对
而且东京这边的
拒签率非常高
以前的话
基本上就是一半一半。
现在基本上就是
大部分都过不了了。
所以其实咱们
现在聊了那么多
你没发现吗？
现在的东京
或者说日本
就有一种
特别荒诞的这种撕裂感。
就是对于游客来说。
日本的汇率低了
他们会觉得日本的东西。
好便宜呀？
对
而且对于留学的人来说。
汇率低了
那么留学的成本也降低了。
对
但是对于咱们
就是生活在日本的外国人。
或者说是日本人来说。
其实生活成本和压力。
都在上升的
那对于咱们
这种生活在日本的。
外国人来说的话
在忍受的物价上涨的。
同时还要遭受了
汇率的影响
因为毕竟有的时候。
还是需要把日元
换成人民币来划
对
就比如说像是日本人的话。
他只能挣日元嘛？
那可能
所以他在出去消费的时候。
反而是一个不小的打击。
所以他们就不出去。
现在都扎到什么冲绳。
或者是九州
或者是白海道去玩。
所以我们在这种
物价上涨的这种压力下。
我们也总结出来了。
一些省钱的一些小技巧。
怎么说的
我觉得这个就是延续了。
咱们当初留学时代的。
一些习惯
然后把习惯列个清单。
然后一点点给他
再完善一下
对
第一个就是最经典的。
半价便当
当然这个半价便当。
不只是便当了
就是说
超市里面在晚上
会有一些打折的东西。
除了便当以外
还有什么熟食
还有什么水果蔬菜。
也都有
但是水果蔬菜
一般是第二天的
一早晨会比较多
它上新的同时
就把旧的给贴了
所以也要是按十段去。
才能买到最划算的。
再包括我们家周围。
哪个超市什么东西便宜。
我们也都摸个门清了。
对
而且现在如果就是。
要买东西的话
先把要买的东西全列出来。
然后挨个去看
这个东西
在哪个超市是更便宜一些。
对
就心里面会有一个大概的规划。
比如说鸡蛋
肉
虾
或者其他的海鲜的东西。
就是去Cosco。
取一下同个货是最划算的。
对
然后需要买一些
中国的那些吃的时候。
可能是去物产店
去集中采购一圈
这样是最划算的
还得去一个特定的物产店。
对 因为它最便宜。
对
所有的物产店都是管它进货的。
虽然它远了一点
但是每一次去采购的量。
还是很划算的
跑这一趟
然后就是像刚才说的。
买一些冷冻的蔬菜类。
或者说一些罐头类。
可以长期保存的
那个的话就是主要在业务超市去办。
对
然后外食的话
想去的话
我觉得是最好午餐的时候去。
因为午市要比晚市便宜太多了。
即使说现在
其实午市已经涨了一些价格了。
但是依然是非常有性价比的。
基本上人群一千多。
就可以吃到比较好的一个午餐。
对 而且有一些店。
午餐的时候会有一些定食的套餐。
它这个晚上是没有的。
然后吃之前要看看。
有没有对应的APP。
有没有优惠券
而且还要记得在结账的时候。
用point
对 用积分去结账。
你说到这个积分
其实也是现在
可能需要去探索的一个领域。
就是日本不是有一个叫做。
point火
poikatsu。
对 一直有
但是积分的这个魅力。
可能现在就越来越体现出来了。
伴随着物价上涨
积分变得越来越有性价比了。
因为这是一个很大的一个系统。
不是说你有这几个APP之后。
你就可以去简单的去运用它。
如果在仔细研究的话。
你会发现
每一个积分的APP。
可以关联不同银行的信用卡。
然后要研究一下
什么APP用什么样的信用卡。
在什么店去消费
是最划算的
就这一套系统
如果你研究通了之后。
会省很多钱
还是挺复杂的
对
很花精力的
因为有一些人他可能。
自己本身他没有工作。
他就是靠这些积分在火。
所以有一些厉害的人。
甚至还上新闻那些人。
他们甚至有几百万的积分。
天天就是
那就是几百万块钱。
对 天天就耗这些积分。
然后去生活
他们甚至生活的
可能比我们的品质还好一些。
那肯定是
几百万积分的几百万日元。
对吗？
真的要是几百万日元。
虽然说是你拿不出来的这些钱。
但是真的你消费的时候。
可以当做钱花的话。
也是非常大的一笔钱。
对不对
所以研究积分这事就靠你了。
咱们家就是百万积分的使命。
就落在你的身上
这个任务有点艰巨。
我相信你
你可以的
那差不多咱们今天。
也聊了挺长时间了。
咱们聊到这
其实这一期就跟大家。
把我们在日本
真实的一个生活水平。
和当地真实的一个物价。
跟大家算是说明白了。
所以你们听完了以后就发现。
其实我们在日本生活。
跟在北京
或者说是上海生活。
也没有什么特别大的差别。
生活状态基本上都是一样。
要去算计这花
要去想一些省钱的办法。
也不是说我们在海外。
就是活得风生水起的。
对不对
其实有不一样的地方。
你在国内的话
可能会活得更滋润一些。
因为毕竟有很多的便利。
但是在国内的话
就没有这么多假期了。
有道理
你周六不得加个班。
你周日不得开个会。
可能是一些
比较好的工作
可能才能有一个很长的假期。
太少了
对吧？
就是够利弊吧？
听到这听众朋友们。
你们如果对于日本的生活。
或者说是日本的物价。
还有什么比较好奇的。
或者说是对我们的生活。
有什么比较感兴趣的。
也可以在评论区里面留言。
我们也会一一去解答。
或者也可以跟我们分享一些。
你们当地的一个物价。
或者说是一个生活状态。
是怎么样的
同样也可以加听众群。
来进群跟大家聊一聊。
你们当地的生活
是一种怎么样的一个状态。
以上就是本期节目的全部内容。
这里是翻台张口
我是老板
我是雪莉
我们下期再见
拜拜